oh boy are the cracks really starting to
[Music]
show so we are going to talk about
Marvel we're going to talk about the MCU
specifically we're going to talk about
their approach to streaming shows which
is getting a complete
overhaul because they seem to have woken
up to the fact that the way they've been
doing it has not been working out very
well so there has been news that has
broke um some of which the information
is pretty well confirmed the other of
which it's not 100% but it fits and
would make sense so while I am going to
be doing an overall analysis of what has
been learned take a certain amount of it
with a grain of salt at least when it
comes to the specifics but the overall
tone of the thing yeah that th this is
something that's happening so on the
back of news this kind of kicked the
whole thing off that Daredevil born
again is effectively getting a reset
that's the Revival of Daredevil that's
coming out on Disney plus that had had
about half its season shot before
strikes shut the whole thing down and
apparently during the strike some of the
executives such as Kevin feige and
others took a look at what had been shot
and realized oh no this this actually
this isn't working we need to uh not
leap right back into production once all
the strikes are fully wrapped up we need
to actually uh stop and reassess and
figure out what we need to do and
whether or not that specifically set off
the move to completely revamp the entire
approach to uh how they're handling
streaming or if they were already
considering uh revamping all that and
the timing of them doing that made them
look at Daredevil again and just the
news of the Daredevil reset broke a
little soon sooner than the news of the
full overhaul of how they're approaching
it it's hard to know but uh they happen
pretty quickly together so before we can
we can understand and appreciate how it
is that things are changing we need to
understand some of the quirks of how
they've been done up to this point now
some of these quirks are inherent to
streaming services many of which aren't
doing things in the manner that a
traditional TV show would uh especially
ones who do the binging model where the
entire thing is dropped pretty much all
at once and that hasn't really been the
case for Disney Plus in particular but
there is again just some inherent
Notions to how streaming has largely
been handled but then there are a lot of
the specifics for how Marvel has chosen
to go about this the short
version is that uh there haven't really
been proper showrunners up to this point
the way traditionally a show whether it
be streaming and especially on uh
television be it cable or network the
way things normally work is you hire a
showrunner who is also generally the
headwriter not 100% of the time but
usually your headwriter is also your
showrunner and they put together a pilot
episode assuming that it isn't uh
ordered straight to series which does
still happen even on the traditional
television formats but they also come up
with a show Bible so that anyone who is
working on um subsequent episodes
because the showrunner is not going to
write everything they have a guide for
what is is or is not allowed to do with
certain characters certain directions
what plot points need to happen at what
point in the season
Etc uh Marvel hasn't been doing that
they haven't had showrunners in fact
there are reports of some cases where
the head writers of some of these shows
have either quit or been squeezed out
this is some of the stuff where these
specifics are a little bit money and not
completely confirmed but some of the um
news that is coming forward is for
instance Jeremy Slater who was the
headwriter on moonnight appears to have
quit or at the very least he's not
coming back to do anymore he has started
working with James gun over in the DC
stuff and then there's Jessica gal who
was the headwriter for She-Hulk and she
was supposedly completely Seline during
production although she may have been
brought back into to help with some of
the post- production but the overall
thing is the normal process is to have a
showrunner who is effectively handling
the creative overarching you'll still
have producers handling the logistical
overarching production but there wasn't
a creative head for most of these shows
or possibly any of them depending on how
you want to look at it but what appears
to have happened in most if not all of
the cases of the MCU Disney Plus shows
is that scripts were turned in and then
writers were shut out now you might
think okay so the directors then picked
up the Reigns and uh handled the things
moving forward well potentially to a
certain degree but it really doesn't
seem to have panned out that way because
as a rule of thumb directors of
individual episodes of a show unless the
same director is do is directing every
single one then generally they're not
taking creative control either they're
coming in to get a script to get uh
General guidelines you know from from
honestly they take a lot of the cues
from the existing production staff the
actors the costomers or whatnot who say
okay this is how my char is like or this
is these are the costumes that have
already been approved for these
characters and the director just works
with what they have they don't take over
creative control and similarly with
editors they just work with what they're
given and so basically the executives
were running the shows now shows will
have executive oversight to varying
degrees and that's true of pretty much
every uh format be it television cable
or streaming but the executives don't
usually run the thing and that's seems
to have been the case not necessarily by
Design but definitely by default if
nothing else a big part of the
overarching problem appears to have been
the fact that since the um outing of Ike
Pearl mutter that basically resulted in
the disillusion of the entire Marvel TV
production end and so the streaming
shows they didn't really have dedicated
TV producers or Executives they were
just being worked on by people who were
ported in from the movie department and
we're like working on shows on like a
one-off basis so these things weren't
even being approached the way you would
approach a TV show they were being
handled largely like movies where the
script gets turned in you shoot it and
if anything went wrong you fix it in
post and yes the fix it and post
mentality which also has not really been
working out for not just MCU but movies
in general lately uh fix it in post is
actually causing a lot of problems but
especially with a TV show which is
longer more often than not than a movie
is to come in with that movie mentality
of we have a script we shoot it and
we'll fix it afterwards if we have to
one of the advantages of TV normally is
that you can fix it as you go and this
format has not allowed for that in any
way shape or form and when you bring in
people from the movie side to run a TV
show they don't understand the
fundamental differences of production
and so they've been handling it like
you'd handle a movie and that has not
worked out well another thing probably
exacerbating this is over the last few
years Marvel has been bringing in
outside Executives as opposed to doing
what they used to do which was to take
high-end creative people and promoting
them up to executive level that happened
with folks like say John favro who
served as an executive producer for
quite a few movies that he did not
direct while he was still working with
the MCU but anyways that's some of what
has been going on and what has caused
some of the hiccups that have happened
uh so what are they now going to do well
they they are intending to structure it
more like a traditional TV show where
you get a showrunner where it is their
job to Shepherd the show as a whole from
creation and scripting through to
completion as opposed to
compartmentalizing everything the way
that they've been doing up to this point
they are intending to have those
showrunners come up with a Bible for the
show and to do a pilot and then for that
pilot to be reviewed and approved so
that they know what the end result is
going to be as opposed to treating it
like a movie where you either Greenlight
it whether you know it's going to work
or not and just hope it does instead
they're going to go back to a more
traditional TV thing so like okay give
us a pilot episode so we can see it and
make sure it works then we give you the
money to start working on the rest of
the thing so they're going to start
doing that there is the intention to
create a TV specific executive so
they're not bouncing back and forth
between movies and television anymore so
that's also a good thing like don't get
me wrong when they ousted Ike Pearl
mutter that was a good thing if you
don't remember this guy Ike pearlmutter
was head of Marvel uh entertainment for
a while until basically Kevin feige
complained about him so much that they
got rid of him and the guy wasn't good
he was the reason that uh roie got
recast literally because he made the
argument no one's going to notice anyway
which okay and he was the one who was
really heavily pushing the Inhumans he
was the one who supposedly was
minimizing the impact of the women
characters and was putting the kibos on
a uh Black Widow movie because in his
mind the toys of a woman superhero
wouldn't sell as well so like the guy
was a jerk and I'm glad he's gone but
the problem was when they got rid of him
and just put everything that was the MCU
under feige that sounded good except the
guy's a movie producer and his team are
movie producers and so they tried to
handle the streaming like it was movies
and it's not so reestablishing a
dedicated team of at the very least
Executives if not working your way down
and building an an entire pipeline at
the very least having Executives whose
only job is to handle television and who
aren't having to worry about well TV
movie okay wait do I do it differently
each time do I do it basically the same
either way regardless of the format
different like we're scrapping all that
dedicated people that's good they should
have done that in the first place
another consequences that future shows
are no longer being planned as limited
miniseries but instead are going to be
approached as something to have
additional seasons in the future which
is another thing that hasn't been the
case Loki has honestly been the
exception and while there's been some
word that other shows might get
follow-ups or second Seasons they
haven't been designed with that in mind
even the ones that ended effectively on
Cliffhangers like moonight did with the
story completely unresolved and no
commitment to coming back and doing more
but that isn't necessarily in and of
itself the problem but again I think
that was probably a result of them
treating it like movies trying to treat
each each series like a oneoff the way
you would normally more or less treat
the movies and again that's not really
the way that TV even streaming TV
generally works now does that mean
everything will automatically get a
second season no but you format a thing
differently when you're trying to hook
people in with the intention of keeping
them coming back season after season
than you do when you think this is a
oneandone and your primary mandate is to
set up puzzle pieces and and load the
bases for a future movie which is what
things like Ms Marvel really felt like
it felt much more about setting up what
would eventually be the Marvels which is
not out yet and won't be for a little
bit at time of recording but that and
indicating a start for the X-Men in some
way ultimately that seemed to be more of
the ultimate purpose of that is to cover
the base for where this character comes
from and it's not worried about whether
or not you want to see a second season
because they're not going to do it
anyway and so again the fact that
they've been doing them as one-offs has
fundamentally hampered the way they've
been approached now again some of these
have been handled better than others as
much as I did not like the ending of w
division as an overall thing that was
handled a bit better as much as the
handling of the villains especially in
uh Falcon and the Winter Soldier is not
very good that is honestly at least
structurally in formatt probably one of
the best that they've done again the
things got problems do not get me wrong
but as far as where it fits into
everything that was a case of okay so
we're going to cover Sam coming to grips
with the idea that he's going to be
Captain America now you could in theory
skip this and just go to the next
Captain America movie where it is him
and for you it just leaps off from the
end of end game where he takes the
shield and okay so he's Captain America
now but if you want to see the Journey
of how he got comfortable assuming that
role here's this show the show wasn't
perfect and it had some serious issues
but like that kind of format seemed to
work but there is a difference between
having a one-off series that kind of
fills in a gap that is kind of optional
and doing something that is just
straight up loading the basis for
something else and doesn't feel like it
is constructed to actually hook you in
and make you love the characters make
you want to come back for them
supposedly also they're going to be be
putting a lot more character focus on
this which again is intended to minimize
the feeling that these are well homework
that you're watching it because if you
don't watch this you won't understand
the MCU stuff you actually care about so
there is already kind of that because
we're going to see we'll see how the
Marvels turns out as a film but I'm
really worried about that one because
right now from the look of it it has the
look and feel of something that if you
did not watch W Division if you did not
watch M Marvel Lord help you if you
didn't see secret Invasion then you're
not going to understand what's going on
with three out of four members of the
core cast whether or not that ends up
being the case fully we'll know when
when the movie comes out but that's
definitely a risk right now and so these
shows were very much feeling like
homework as opposed to a product
intended to entertain there
now appear to have realized why that's
bad and are attempting to fix it whether
or not they will we'll see if I'm being
completely honest Marvel really is
heading for a situation that is kind of
what DC's been dealing with since the SN
verse kind of imploded in on itself now
granted there were additional
exacerbating factors with this SNY
stepping away from Justice League partly
because of a family tragedy amongst
other things but it was very clear the
studio had lost confidence in his um
Vision at that point anyway but but that
is that as these things have gone on
there's been a lack of central Creative
Vision and really just a vision of
producers now why has Marvel lasted so
much longer than DC especially
considering that they started sooner and
theoretically should have hit the road
bump sooner well honestly part of it is
luck and also part of it is DC was
trying to speedrun what Marvel was doing
which just made them prone to hitting
the speed bumps a lot harder if not
sooner but Marvel got lucky in a number
of ways when you actually look back and
realize how long this has gone on they
flat out lucked out and I think that
luck is running out let me explain what
I mean by they got lucky part of the
thing with Marvel right now is as I said
this is not
really creative driven this is producer
driven this is Kevin feige's MCU much
more than it is anybody else's now that
hasn't always been the case but the
times when it hasn't been the case
have been relatively short-lived or sort
of little bit not flukes but exceptions
honestly you look at the creators that
were brought into the original batch of
films for the MCU you had folks like
John favro a talented created person not
really known as a Visionary though as a
director you had people like Lewis leier
kind of the same thing Kenneth BR
arguably a bit more of a sing Vision as
a director though of varying results Joe
Johnston bit of a Workman if we're being
honest like he fit because he done stuff
like The Rocketeer which was evoking the
same kind of era that Captain America
the First Avenger was but again not a
ton of excessively strong directorial or
creative voices now when they brought in
Jos Weeden to do the original Avengers
and yes I know we all hate Jos Sweden
now I've got my own issues with him
there's the last video I did on him so
I'm not doing this to praise him I'm
just talking about the impact on the
overall thing he came in with a much
clearer creative voice whether you like
that voice or not is a separate issue
but he definitely had one but by the
time he finished age Voltron he bowed
out because he was feeling the hand of
the executives over him who wanted to
dictate what he was doing and he felt
like he couldn't be creative anymore and
after that that's where they got really
lucky they got really lucky with the
Russo brothers because if you look at
the filmographies of a lot of these
directors that the Marvel Cinematic
Universe has brought in not all of them
but a fairly decent amount of them are
either relatively new and only have a
couple films under their belts or they
have more experience in television than
in film now in a way that's very
beneficial because I kind of mentioned
before directors from television aren't
used to imposing that stronger Creative
Vision because the characters are
pre-existing the the uh the world is
pre-existing the costumes you know so
much stuff is determined before they
even get there so they're used to just
taking the pieces that they're given and
putting things together in a way that
will be entertaining and consistent with
what's come before and that is a skill
that a TV director needs to have and
that was a skill that Marvel needed some
of their MCU directors to have and when
I say they got lucky with the Russo
Brothers here's the thing the Russo
Brothers you can argue don't have
particular
strong directorial or creative voice but
I would argue that something they are
very good at is taking the pieces
dictated to them by an executive and
forming them into something that works
that is a skill and it's a skill not
everybody has just like not everybody
has the skill to have a singular
Creative Vision that they are prepared
to see through from pre-production all
the way to finished release and maintain
and fight for their Vision all the way
through the russos given me the
impression of not being that kind of
directors but what they are good at is
making sure that they get the the notes
from the executives keep them happy but
still come out with a coherent and
effective product that's not an easy
thing to do and it's not something that
everybody can do so they really got
lucky that they got in television guys
who would take the notes but also had
enough of a strong sense of what it was
that was being done to basically keep
the Train on the tracks and since they
left you've felt that absence now there
have been some instances of creative
voices and people with very clear um
creative focus and their own flare that
they've brought to this you've got James
Gunn you've got Ryan cougler but the
thing is even with some of the more
interesting or artsy choices that have
been made with some of the directors
like say Khloe Z or taoti by and large
these are people who don't have
experience directing with something this
big this much money and this much
action so in a lot of cases they're only
directing about half the
movie they are directing the stuff with
the actors having dialogue but they're
handing over all the action to the
second unit which is basically its own
thing now second unit is there to film
whatever the director themselves aren't
filming and that may or may not include
action scenes depend depending on
whether the director wants to do those
things but in the case of Marvel we have
heard from some people who have opted
out of doing a Marvel movie such as Ava
deer that she wasn't going to be allowed
to even learn how to do the action
direcly they were just going to hand
that off to the second unit who were
going to do it the way they'd always
done it and she would just handle
everything else and that really does
hamper what creative people can do even
people with unique distinct voices and
you've seen that even honestly from Far
earlier Edgar Wright was supposed to
direct an Ant-Man movie before the MCU
was even a thing he'd been working on
this and he ultimately left because he
just wasn't feeling like he could
deliver the vision he wanted to make and
he was replaced by pton Reed whose
filmography is television and romcoms
somebody who'll take the notes and do
what he can with them now I know it's
weird that I've just gone off for a bit
about the movies when I started off
talking about the streaming but I'm
trying to lay the groundwork here for
the mentality of why the MCU as a whole
is where it currently is and how we got
into the situation where the streaming
situation ended up where it's at because
even as the MCU continues to on occasion
bring in some more creative and very
talented and unique directorial voices
they have not let them do do their own
thing very often James gun is the big
exception Ryan cougar seems to be the
second one other than that I mean Sam Ry
a little bit he certainly got to put his
visual flare all over Multiverse of
Madness how involved he was in the story
hard to say so can Marvel write this
ship maybe now I know there are some
people out there who are just going to
claim it's it's superhero fatigue that
actually none of the m was ever good and
it's just everybody's realizing that and
while I don't think superhero fatigue is
invalid I don't think that's the whole
story The approach that Marvel has been
using that worked for as long as it did
partly because they just got really
lucky with the people that they lined up
and once Weeden left and the Russo
Brothers left the thing has just been
ambling
along like something being headed by
Executives as opposed to a central
creative force and Kevin feige is is a
very talented producer and he's been
juggling a lot but he's not a creative
Force I don't think he necessarily even
thinks he is but he did seem to think
that he could basically sideline the
creative forces bring them in for you
know the script get a decent director
but like so many parts of this has just
been taken out of the hands of the
creatives and honestly a lot of it is
felt like Ai and in fact in secret
evasion the opening credits literally
were created by AI this is the kind of
stuff that the strike has been all about
both strikes the writer strike which at
time of recording has resolved the SAG
strike which at time of recording has
not resolved yet we'll see what happens
by the time this comes out but this
mentality of okay we can automate a lot
of this whether or not AI has literally
been used in the MCU other than those
opening credits of of secret Invasion I
probably not I don't think so but the
mentality that leads Executives to think
AI is a good
idea has been in place the modular
format we have our second unit they
handle all the action so when we bring
in writers they hand us a script and
they go away and they've been doing the
streaming shows like that even though
normally on streaming you get a
showrunner who is also a writer who
Shepherds the thing all the way through
and they just haven't done it and they
bring in director okay shoot the script
that has been approved and the action
scenes are already taken care of go so
how much of a flare the director is
going to be able to put on things is
going to be limited because they have
sectioned off and made into modules all
these different aspects pre-production
is basically completely handled on its
own almost separate from the creatives
because they have whatever supposed
overarching plan then they're currently
working towards I I think it's Secret
Wars and as they head that way a lot of
decisions are going to be made either
before a director is even brought on
board or made that in a way that the
director doesn't really get to change
even if the movie they would like to
make would be something else so that
mentality which is an executive
mentality has been driving Marvel for a
while and they're Lu has run out they've
been making these movies these shows
this universe
unsustainably and it lasted I feel
personally quite strongly through
endgame but since
then you've seen it start to Veer off
the
rails and I'm going to argue that it's
the lack of a clear creative controlling
force that hasn't been there for the
product as a whole and that really
hasn't been there for most of the
individual shows that have gone out on
streaming now at time of talking and
recording there's no word on whether a
similar overhaul of Star Wars might be
in the mix that might happen that might
not they do have uh Dave filon who seems
to be acting as the primary creative
Force so they do have one over with the
Star Wars streaming stuff but they've
still been doing the whole bunch of
limited series thing there is the
Mandalorian which has gotten multiple
seasons and Andor is going to get two
but that is effectively still a limited
series because they knew coming in they
were only going to do two seasons and
they knew the format of them so I
wouldn't be shocked if there is also
some restructuring over on the Star Wars
end but it might not have to be as
drastic because again they did have
people like Dave filon who were only
handling the streaming stuff and the
movies were being handled completely
separately so Star Wars is probably in a
better position but I wouldn't be
shocked if we see a dialing back of the
limited series that aren't intended to
continue any further especially if this
shift in Marvel proves to be more
effective But ultimately this is also
dovetailing and bumping up against the
potential bursting of the streaming
bubble because yeah streaming is a
bubble and has been for a while here's
the thing none of these streaming
services not Disney plus not Max not
Paramount plus not peacock none of these
are
profitable the amount of money that they
have to SN in just to build the
infrastructure just to be able to store
all these shows and have them be
accessed and be able to be streamed at a
decent rate enough to be shown on
people's TV when it streams to their
television that infrastructure alone is
massively expensive and then these
places because they're not Netflix or at
least Netflix back in the day where they
can just hoard everything they might
have a lot of stuff in their back
catalog Disney certainly had that going
for them but the expectation is to keep
people on you have to keep making new
stuff and they're making new series at
the cost of a a uh big budget movie a
piece like they're spending upwards of
$150 million on these
series but how much revenue is that
generating that is literally impossible
to say because you don't know how many
people signed up for your service on the
basis of that show coming out or on the
basis of that made for streaming movie
that you made or who are sticking around
and not canceling their subscription
because you have made more MCU stuff it
is their belief that that is the case
but they can't really quantify that they
can look at the streaming numbers and
the viewing numbers but how many of
those are people watching cuz I'm
already here and have the subscription
and how many people actively chose to
come here because of that that's really
hard to quantify and more to the point
because these things don't make money
each time they're run the way things on
traditional television did because they
would bring in the ad Revenue nor is
there the rental service like
Blockbuster back in the day where they
get money every time somebody Rents It
they're just throwing money in a hole
that's what streaming has become it's
become a money pit for pretty much
everything that isn't Netflix now
Netflix is technically profitable in
terms of they are making more than they
are spending but don't think that
they're off the hook because they have
mountains of debt that they ran up to
build what they became now they're
chugging along because I said they are
at least profitable but they're not in
that much of a staer position than
anybody else streaming does not bring in
what the old formats brought in that
doesn't bring in what network television
does what cable does what rental of
physical Media or sale of physical media
does it's honestly kind of the movie
pass thing you pay one thing a month and
then you watch as much or as little as
you
want but the company only makes that
subscription from you per month
regardless of how much or how little you
watch and
so figuring out how much revenue each
thing is generated is almost impossible
because it just isn't set up that way
that's not how it works anymore I mean
that's a big part of why streaming
wasn't giving residuals the way that
other formats did part of it was
difficult to quantify but also because
you know networks and Studios were upus
skating all this and did didn't want to
pay royalties the writer strike resolved
that for them hopefully it'll resolve
for the actors as well but the streaming
models aren't
sustainable they're just
not because you're just making and
throwing money at all these
projects honestly at this point just to
keep the people you have because for the
most
part most people who want your service
probably have it like you'll get
fluctuations some people will come some
people will go but
there's only so much you can do to get
people to subscribe eventually that
levels out of the ceiling that's also
why everything's jacking up in price
right now now I'm going to stop this
tangent here because this kind of gets
into a whole other thing that I might
dedicate a whole video onto about the
unsustainability of most of these models
because this dovetails into everything
from what Unity pulled to what only fans
tried to pull a little while back the
fact that pretty much all these
businesses are built on what is
initially an unsustainable model and
they know that and part of the plan down
the line well either part of the plan or
what will eventually become a necessity
is to make the service worse and charge
more for it do less get paid more
because what you were doing originally
didn't actually make you money it just
suckered people in and you're now going
to milk them but again I feel like if
that's a topic I'm going to go any
deeper on I need to dedicate a whole
video on it so I need to stop that there
but Disney all of them really are not in
great shape when it comes to these
streaming services and the fact that
Disney has tied so much of Marvel to the
streaming services even if they can
write the ship creatively which I hope
they can do I have not liked that much
of what's come out of the MCU lately but
I want to I still like most of these
properties and characters and I can go
back to earlier parts of this and go
that was good and I can hope for it to
be that again can they maybe creatively
will it be enough I don't know because
at a certain point even if Marvel starts
working again creatively so that the
viewing numbers go up and the uh
critical response gets back to where it
was there's a lot of other stuff
cracking and breaking right now that
might Force things to change
regardless
it's all interconnected it's all
complicated and
no nobody's going broke because they're
woke they're going broke because they
built an unsustainable business
model and unsustainable business models
don't sustain
shock in any case what do you think
about all this what do you think about
the way Marvel had been handling
streaming up to this point what do you
think about the direction they intend to
take it do you think that it'll be
enough and if you want to throw in your
thoughts on the overall problem like I
went off on the last little bit here
yeah feel free to give me your thoughts
on that too drop them all down in the
comments let's talk about it patreon
pays the bills and enables me to do this
as my living but uh even if you can't
help me out that way like share
subscribe also helpful links to other
things I do down in the description but
don't worry too much about it what I
really want you to remember is that you
are
beautiful you are valid you are
loved you are the council I'm just
running the meetings and until next time
this council is
[Music]
adjourned time to thank some patreon
backers and in the spirit of October I'd
like to thank Robin Moore Zubin L Fuller
goddess alter Trac the thing that goes
dink in the anime Ruth Oliver B solitary
pictures or bton Melinda Walter
Jen Auntie Kate 808 Becky Sparks falx
the poodle Robin Powell Tracy scrapit
angry caspel Dave Hall and rosn
Bennett thank you for your assistance um
I don't know I might try theming the
shout outs in the future I don't know
we'll see thank
[Music]
you
oh